ma chi cazzo non ce la posso fare bene a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questa nuova
versione di canto no veramente stavo
registrando non l'avete visto niente
quanti di voi mi chiedono come mi
preparo prima di fare i video che sa è
la risposta bene sono tutto rosso per un
motivo se ve lo state chiedendo siamo
tornati su happy wheels credo si spera
vabbè ragazzi iniziamo prima che diventi
più trash di quanto non sia già di suo
cos'è super ma seriamente su per steve
64 ragazzi altro che supermario è molto
più atletico soprattutto in tema su will
only working flash ma [ __ ] e io
voglio la full version stranzi se fosse
successa una cosa del genere a mario non
oso pensare le reaction ma veramente ma
giù giù certo che ovviamente i tubi sono
diventati trampolini ma mi sembra ovvio
ragazzi a partissero ecco intanto
spariscono kubica mi sembra di giocare
kit mario ragazzi altro che supermario
porca [ __ ]
sì l'ho fatta ho vinto il super mario
più difficile che abbia mai fatto nella
mia vita ragazzi forcelle giù dai quali
importiamo delle cose serie perché mica
già siamo partiti col semplice blocco
set
ma io nome oddio oddio nei tipi di
giochi nuovi sono un fenomeno quando mi
mettono davanti a un gioco nuovo che non
ho mai fatto molto reattivo nel senso
capisco subito come si gioca
sì allora terminati poiché è difficile
sta roba
se icesave sony rossi quindi questo ma
chi è fini
devo andare sui sei più in poche parole
madonna in casino
porca [ __ ] ladra mi mangi piedino ha
seriamente non ha vita impossibile ok il
salto della madonna se mi sono spezzato
le gambe ma forte sega no io ti amo io
ti amo non puoi mollarmi così cazzo come
faccio la giornata dai che ce la posso
fare ciò posso fare tirati suoi no
lou reed a puntare ha mai tradito me lo
ricorderò come ho fatto a morire rivolta
dai regalone possibile cioè per una
volta che già sta facendo senza doveri
provare un miliardo di volto mio dio
come dio tutto carico tutto carico
ma chi è che bella posizione che c è di
scusa mimì dimentico i nomi amico io
come ci si sente a strisciare la faccia
su un arcobaleno daylight cos'è sta cosa
mi il nome e la madonna
no no no no che sì no no no no quando
stronzo di merda mori madonna che botta
gli ho dato
vai così è guerra è guerra ha perso una
gamba ma è sempre guerra che ha preso la
barba bastardi marini come un classico
nella scarpa ecco i sun plex ragazzi
incredibile guarda la gente come ti
permetti di crescere e uno stupro ma io
non ho capito cosa dovevo fare in italia
dovevo superarlo cielo saltarlo così
ecco qua pupa mila fava bravissimo che
salto la madonna ma anche in gta si
salti ma è così lo uso come il tappeto
perchè perchè l'hai fatto steve cosa è
successo c'è stato un omicidio così a
caso io vado vado vado di software
mica sono un violento regala basso
livello e troppo figo che c'è una
grafica che non ho mai visto in going
med ma più o meno che è figo ragazzi non
erano mai giocato a livello ma che
perché c'è la gente morta per te li
mortacci tua mi fai passare st kamata lo
tranciare o cosa è trans ecco cos'è
ragazzi in transformers
mamma [ __ ] mezz'ora per saltare quel
tipo è impossibile perché successo
ragazzo livello emma è bene il senso di
questa cosa
ok toxic boom ti sei intossicato sul
serio prima di fare sta roba
dimmelo di la verità trading jobs devo
facciamo questo perché mi chiamano sta
diventando sempre più strani li vede
direbbe insomma va bene la madonna che
sa che salto del cast calmi i nuovi tra
l'altro mi fa che bello mentre
sgambettava in aria ok ok ma sono gli
atleti ragazzi gli atleti guardalo vabbè
ho perso il casco ma chi se ne freghi
sono un'atleta vera non c'è bisogno non
ho fatto tutto io tu mi hai fatto un
cazzo tutto livello ma va bene è più il
games 1 st roba tutti livelli strani
oggi quindi mini game su altro l'ho
mancato sì l'ho presa col manico lo
infine va beh è già qualcosa da adesso
devo buttare le bottiglie se le mie
braccia fossero stati i cat
ditemi voi se no allora devo rifare il
livello perché le braccia mi sono
rimasti in casa c'è mi rendete conto
disagio porca [ __ ] dano piano mi
piaceva potremo fare show the box e il
lancio è giusto
ok ok perfetto grande sono passi avanti
rock swing no no ok picchiati stava
ammazzando come un deficiente perfetto
famiglie da chi sei fai vedere chi sei
ma se ciò fatto no sono ucciso il pube
ce la posso fare
ma dimmi che non solo vi prego dimmi che
si no tirati su merda famiglia sulle
tecniche botta di caiolo fatto male
secondo voi ragazzi ok ok madonna che
capriole da proprio fare miniball forma
finirà sto livello prima o poi
continuerà così tutta la vita fatemi
capire in piedi sui pallini maledizione
magnate lì piuttosto madonna e disagio
jackson ma basta così sean jones è ok e
uno spy phone che culo che culo
veramente da ragazzi è stata una purga
suo livello ma ce l'ho fatta
l'importante quattro hub swing colors
basta siro dai dai dai dai dai dai
ok
mamma mia che botta però sono rimbalzato
non so come ma va bene si sofferma in
teoria dovrei uscire andare avanti
uguale difatti lo sapevo cioè da me che
non faccio rops indecente fai vedere che
non è per tutto tocco idiota cazzo è
quella roba di rega died for it si
esploso qualcosa me non me ne frega un
cazzo basta che ho vinto 6 di rossano no
basta non voglio sarà il mio figlio
ecco scontenti sta bene è stronzo ha
ucciso mio figlio pazienza ma perché i
maniaci di dono fare neri che razzismo
ma no ma cosa col manico ma dai cazzo
non è possibile ma veramente in italia e
non c'è una katana di 4 metri sulla
schiena e non si ferma non è possibile
dai cazzo mi chiamo zara per fare un
secondo e 70 smadonna un record nostra
madonna o boltro serio da un caso il
trash e le metto tutte nel cestino posso
andare io nel cestino
guarda le butto tutte dentro tanto so
che nemmeno basta una per vincere no
veramente ne dovrebbero esservi e due
perché devo prima sbloccarla
sì il 30 pallet sì però se vanno a
finire sulla morte ciò nel culo dove
cazzo fuoco me che si faccia vincere no
non ci credo ma sei serio ho vinto con
un braccio ma veramente io sono avanti
48 anche i machete con un braccio che
non ce l'ho staccato ma sono un fenomeno
su pes feedback cos'è stato vabbè
qualcos'altro cazzo fai nonno che cazzo
successo miotti nova benefica questo
dovrei fare troppo io si scava 33 57
tipo così
sì 33 va bene ecco il blocco di youtube
to machine fire cos'è sta cosa cioè una
roba tipo oh mio dio che cosa ok
devo andare dritto cos'è lo stava bene
aveva degli spasmi sto ragazzo
[Musica]
way to survive facciamo questo che
ancora basta ti prego che si facendolo
colpe ne allontana col pene
ecco vedi il mio pacco è più forte della
serie perché sono ancora vivo con traore
reverse no che figo vedevo bellissima
cosa
scusa a dio che non volevo devo andare
insieme no no no no no non me la
genialata ragazzi devo farlo al
contrario mi che non avevo mai pensato a
sta cosa
oltre non vedo un cazzo tipo di storie
va bene ma perfetto vinto ok è stato più
facile di quanto pensassi you can't io
clark kent madonna che pessima anche
questa è la roba tipo imposti boss
maniero bellissimo sono un fenomeno si
chiama che cazzo ne impossibile ragazzo
mi faccio a finirlo ha censito you can't
quindi tu non puoi non si può finire ma
io lo finisco stesso perché sono un
[ __ ]
no niente non ce la faccio riguardava
modo in croce ci sarà per finirlo che
non è possibile a meno che non salti
primo piano
no sì sì sì no no no no ma [ __ ] ma
sei serio cosa acciai al collo zero no
dai raga ma sul serio mi chiaro arrivato
dai dai cazzo dai cazzo c'è sì che figo
è stato un parto partorito dei bambini
più bambini cazzo lista mobili o mio dio
devo giocare a calcio con nonno ciak
ma non ci sa giocare non lo sciacca
calcio larghe roba come lei testa però
madonna che fallo che porta gli ho dato
ragazze ok di cuma donna che voglio
replay subito ci ho fatto una rock cos'è
ma cos'è dita di tacco a contrario
superfantastico un altra roba non l'hai
l'atro di penn è perfetto anche di culo
se ce l'hai non chiedetemi come ho fatto
non ne ho idea va bene così ragazzi la
finale dei mondiali tre gol così
fantastici supramonte bruxelles fir o
mio dio più se sta roba veramente sono
infilato un razzo nel didietro ed è tipo
da gravità della luna più fiducia come
hanno fatto a calibrare la gravità della
luna con un razzo nel culo vabbè
dettagli si ingegnano sempre di più nei
livelli legata sia mista conosco ecco
infatti l'obiettivo no cazzo evo che
faceva peso faceva peso sono andato
veramente sulla luna è una storia triste
e finita così
avg e youtube 2 facciamo questo ok favi
tv ai quasi azzeccato nome zio quasi
amico chi è quel chi dovrebbe essere
quella in alto a sinistra dei cachi
dovrei essere io quello ma per favore
lasci mi lasci mila scimmia incredibile
amico così ragazzi non ci credo che va
beh posso fare ciò posso fare ci posso
fare no ce la farò mai
vabbè nabaffa che spaccata sexy per
ragazzi devo riuscirci a fare sta roba è
un po difficile però forse forse un
cazzo cazzo non è un letto quello non
puoi dormire regalare un è possibile che
non riesca a finire un livello dove mi
hanno rappresentato in modo così brutto
dai cassetti
si no no ma come no ma [ __ ] ma chi
è che ha ucciso vive di questi veicoli
youtube 2 questi sono i due ragazzi che
non conobbe l'episodio di aiuti perché è
stato alquanto strano oggi servito è
piaciuto l'assalto momento mi piace
anche a pace di facebook e povera di
vita tranne l'estinzione cioè sei ore si
discute civile o lo fossimo video delle
ragazze
[Musica]